hello I'm Patti Harrison and I'm Joel
Kim booster and you're watching on sand
where we celebrate the best and the
worst of the web but mostly the worst
[Music]
[Applause]
this issue needs to be addressed as
quickly as it needs to be stopped
hot girls on Instagram taking way too
many pictures of themselves eating junk
food
are these biddies Pappajohn influencers
or am i missing something
why so much pizza I'm sure you've all
picked up on the fact that I myself am a
hot hot little girl but when I eat
pizza I just suck it all in okay I don't
invite a glam squad over and take a
bunch of pics of us squattin poppin and
squats eatin and licking on pizza and
there's the time Sarah hash Croft made a
shocking announcement in her photo
depicting her eating Froot Loops whilst
wearing a bikini
buy me a box of Froot Loops and I'm all
yours girl a box of Froot Loops 250
before coupons what are you doing with
your life you're supposed to be
influencing and this is your self-worth
two dollars two dollars our society is
crumbling first gay marriage and now
model is eating Froot Loops also how
come her body looks but but her hair is
dry I need answers hot girls of insta
stop pretending like you're doing us a
favor and trying to come across as
relatable or people Olivia Holt doesn't
even put cream cheese on her bagels
she's going to be an active shooter very
soon her Instagram page looks like it's
showcasing Christian Bale's diet for his
role as Dick Cheney and Vice Olivia stay
in your lane girl we've all sent
something said something tweeted
something that we wish we could unsend
today esther povitsky is going to share
her shameful unsend because the only way
to unsend a nun send is to talk about it
thanks for being here Esther thank you
for providing me with a platform to tell
this story that I'm going to regret
telling for the rest of my life a long
time ago I had started dating someone
new who was a little bit out of my
league I'll say it in what way he was
tall and handsome tall doesn't
necessarily mean handsome though do you
just mean he was tall and any any man
who's like meets my eye level here I'm
like fine in any man who meets my if my
I if I when I talk to you of my
do like this I will kill for you you're
a my god I'll kill for you but if you're
here I'm like hey so as the strong smart
empowered businesswoman that I am I was
like he's out of my league I need to
figure out how to keep him I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna see if squirting is
real right I don't know it might be look
was I super thin and had a great body
not really was I at all classically
attractive beautiful woman no I wasn't I
was just me on a mission to squirt yeah
that's really romantic beautiful it is
romantic I'm gonna cry so I do pants I
do panty and I go in I'm poking and
prodding and pointing and laughing I'm
smiling I'm crying
hopefully I'm squirting but I'm not sure
there's different wets that can come out
yeah I don't have that knowledge I don't
have that experience there's a lot more
room in there than I thought so wait how
much room do you think is in there I
don't know I thought it was mostly like
a butt butt in the front and then I
remembered that I had a pretty close
friendship with a woman who wasn't porn
who better to ask I have a direct line
of contact with someone who actually
knows this as opposed to like doing all
this google searching so I text her and
it's a long text you know we're talking
a true paragraph I told her that there's
a liquid I can't quite tell is it maybe
piss maybe so I include that in the text
I hit Send she responds no I opened the
text and it says who is this and I just
never responded and look I can tell you
who I am any day of the week that's
right but if you just received a text
about me possibly pissing myself and my
twin size but I can not tell you my name
after that and I think that's fair I'm
not using this as a pejorative I just
think you were mentally ill I think that
I was in my early 20s and those are the
same thing
Joe baby what no I don't what's going on
here I don't trust whatever is happening
the last time you are this nice to me
you stole my identity that instinct
isn't wrong I'm about to destroy you
here's the thing here at unsend we poke
a lot of fun and we enjoy taking the
piss so to counteract that snark I dug
around the web to find something that
will grab you by the lower intestine
push up through your throat and spill
out your eyeballs
[Music]
are you identifying with the cat and
nurse is that what your sad yes Lucas
say it was sad it was sad because three
people died in that apartment fire and
they glossed right over that to focus on
one cat he let them die because they
were gay
he's a homophobic firefighter who loves
cats do you feel good about your tears
now Patti wait how do you know they were
gay because I could sense them dying
something that a lot of people don't
know about gay people is that when
another gay person dies we feel it
that's the same for trans people but
it's like any time you see someone okay
let's not make this a political show
everybody at home this is patty Harrison
I've been silenced again and this is
Joel Kim booster and we're on send where
I'm saying
[Music]
you